well you just recently started a new
podcast with Joey called the check-in
how does that feel moving from the
producer seat to the full-time official
co-host of the show just a few years
later it's pretty I I never thought I'd
be a co-host of anything when we started
the church I didn't want to be on camera
or on the mic I wanted to you know let
Joey go crazy and I've been having a lot
of fun with the checkin it's a it's
different we have we have a lot of fun
we have a lot of laughs you know the the
reason why we called it the checkin is
because that's what Joey does with me
and everyone is he he checks in on on
people we know that there are a lot of
people who who could use that right now
and who were fans of and and listen to
the church and you know we're not trying
to be the number one podcast we're just
trying to to have fun genuinely be who
we are and talk about things that we're
interested in and you know just have a
little bit of fun every week that's
awesome I feel like that authenticity is
really shining through and people are
super interested to see you guys back
together